en matière d'essais nucléaires français
dans le pacifique
quelle confiance peuvent avoir les
polynésiens ont la parole de l'état 55
ans après le premier essai nucléaire en
polynésie la question est toujours
présent est ce que l'état a été
totalement transparent sur les
conséquences sanitaires de ces
expériences de juillet 1966 l'armée
française procède aux premiers essais
nucléaires à l'air libre
au total il y en aura 46 depuis l'atoll
de mururoa en polynésie
la télévision se fait alors le
porte-voix de l'armée tous seraient sous
contrôle 80% des moyens mis en place
dans le pacifique sont consacrés à la
sécurité
le commandement au moment où il appuiera
sur le bouton se rassure que personne ne
risque de contaminer il faudra attendre
1971 pour qu'enfin la question des
retombées des nuages radioactifs soient
posées mais là encore le cea rassure les
politiciens monte dans la haute
atmosphère
mais à ce moment là ils retombent très
lentement dans une dure elle a le temps
de retomber total peut être supérieur à
l'année ou même à deux années est au
bout de ce délai la grande majorité des
produits radioactifs se sont désintégrés
et les retombées correspondances ne sont
plus radioactifs la même année les
journalistes s'interrogent aussi sur les
potentiels contamination des légumes ou
des fruits cultivés en polynésie réponse
du médecin biologiste immédiatement
après les tirs nous effectuons sur les
îles et atolls des prélèvements de
produits consommables qui sont envoyés
pour analyse à papeete
il n'y a pas en général donc de risque
et l'alimentation
il n'y a aucun risque de contamination
par l'e de 1966 à 1974 l'armée va
procéder à 46 essais nucléaires à me
revois ils seront peu médiatisé est
contestée par les voisins néo-zélandais
et australien alors à partir de 1974
les expériences ont toujours lieu en
polynésie mais à plus de 600 mètres sous
terre
une façon de reconnaître que les esea
vers libres était dangereux
pas du tout selon le commissariat à
l'énergie atomique nos effets n'étaient
pas dangereux et n'a en aucun cas ne
mettait en péril la santé des
populations
il n'en restait pas moins une certaine
radio haïti et que nous libérions dans
la cua
désormais on a résolu intégralement le
problème la radioactivité
maintenant elle est à sangatte alpha est
à plus de 600 mètres sous terre
elle y restera pour l'éternité pourtant
selon une récente enquête de disclose
cent dix mille personnes ont été
dangereusement exposées à la
radioactivité
entre 1966 et 1974 soit la quasi
totalité de la population des habitants
de tahiti et des îles alentour
[Musique]